[Music]
put it up there and it's true i'm not
picky except around scabs
ah that's pretty good i like that one
clap it's friday clap
away stop tapping
clap again
all right
happy friday everyone what an amazing
week we've had for one the legacy media
is dying what is the legacy media you
ask exactly my point in another year or
two it's going to be a distant memory a
relic part of a bygone era like silent
films eight-track tapes and the late
show with colbert
in short it's the monster that
manufactures absurd narratives from this
thing called life
sounds like i'm describing a bette
midler one woman show
but it's worse
unlike me and my staff the legacy media
rights creates and produces not for you
but for their industry to feed their own
egos and bank balances it's a
self-preservation hive mind but like a
hospital powered by windmills they
operate only in darkness
i don't know why i'm doing that
but when the lights go on they die like
ants under a magnifying glass at high
noon you're seeing it now the
manipulation bubble in all its nakedness
but like that two-way mirror i installed
in my guest bathroom
it's a bubble they claim to see out of
but won't let you see in
but you see it all right now and you've
seen it before in drips and drabs
because sometimes the news is so
orchestrated it makes the ohio state
marching band look spontaneous
take the holidays or the last weeks of
summer the news just stops
it's not like life stopped or life
suffering stopped or crime suddenly went
away no the faucet just got turned off
because the people who run the news
are at the hamptons
did you notice how nothing happens
during the super bowl you'd think that
would be the best time for something
newsy to occur but no
it's like even hezbollah al qaeda low
leave street thugs and even hurricanes
and tornadoes have money on the big game
and aside from some intimately situated
bottle rocket injuries
nothing happens on july 4th
and yes the world is still turning but
there's no one there to create the spin
meanwhile throughout the year actual
news is avoided in favor of
conflict-driven click bait making people
angry is their business model they
prefer that we be mad at each other as
the deficit hits 30 trillion the borders
a mess and crime runs rampant because
that stuff throws their authority into
question
now how can you tell the legacy media is
truly dying well they're turning their
fire not towards people who want to
limit speech but towards those who
create more speech meaning the people
whipping their ass turns out democracy
dies when you get 10 times their best
audience
what do you say doughboy
not all opinions are created equal you
think about major newsrooms like cnn
that have health departments and deaths
and operations that work hard on
verified information october 19. and
then you have talk show stars like joe
rogan who just wing it who make it up as
they go along and because figures like
rogan are trusted by people that don't
trust real news rooms we have attention
a problem that's much bigger than
spotify
yeah you should ask why they don't trust
you but he's panicked you can tell by
the sweat his dome is shinier than a
christmas ornament but he shouldn't
worry when cnn goes away he can always
work directly for the dnc
and i hear they have great donuts in the
break room but cnn claims the truth is
in danger we need action right now which
is how legacy media tries to protect
itself by silencing the competition they
tried to do it to trump now their new
target replacing trump is rogan but it's
too late cnn is in a death spiral and
why is this important because for the
longest time they had us there was no
alternative cnn was up there with death
and taxes viewers were like suckers
paying 10 bucks for an awful pre-made
ham and cheese sandwich at the airport
where else are you going to go but
that's changed here's a fact
liberals and democrats now watch fox
more than they watch cnn or even msnbc
new nielsen ratings showed that in
october tucker was the number one
watched host among democrats in the key
25 to 54 age demographic across all
networks rachel maddow and the five tied
for second
and something called gutfeld rounded out
the top five never heard of them
poor cnn not only are we eating their
lunch we're doing it in their kitchen
with stuff from their fridge
so you can grow some amazing conclusions
from this first the fox audience isn't
as easy to define as the bitter left
would have it to be so when they insult
our viewers often they insult themselves
our viewers are what's that word diverse
but this is what happens cnn when you
betray your viewers by claiming
something's true when it turns out to be
a lie over and over and over again roll
that montage marvin show me where it
says that protests are supposed to be
polite and peaceful what does putin have
on trump
has trump been compromised this was the
actual swab that was being used to fit
up that double barrel shotgun that you
have mounted on the front of your pretty
face we are not fake news we are real
news if you watch a certain state tv and
you listen to conservative media you
would think that you know
entire cities are just you know enrolled
in fights and fires and whatever we went
out had a great dinner the biggest
terror threat in this country comes from
radicals on the far right primarily
white men much of the dossier has been
corroborated some rioters were planning
to murder lawmakers but it does look
like that young man to me is taunting
the native american vietnam vet
and he's in his face
no wonder cnn is trying to build a
censorship version of the berlin wall i
wouldn't want anyone to point out that
crap either cena just makes everything
else look better especially rogan when
he's wrong at least he didn't have an
entire news room to blame
so like the drifter clawing his way out
in my trunk
legacy media needed to die
they ignore crime and inflation in the
border things that affect you but not
them they created russian collusion to
help hillary they laughed off the crime
wave to protect the progressives they
denied that hunter's laptop was real
they claimed racism is now a health
hazard which shouldn't matter since
we'll all be dead in eight years
thank you climate change
cnn is like the stripper that tells you
you're so handsome during a lap dance
but everything they told you was a lie
just to make a profit
i wouldn't know
but now they're that wounded gazelle
that can't keep up with the pack
and we're that pack of lions ready to
finish the job it's just nature playing
out the way it's supposed to where the
strong survive and the weak get eaten
and man does cnn taste delicious
[Applause]
welcome tonight's goose
she's a triple threat in the sense that
she threatened me three times today
mtv's hottest vj aside from matt
pinfield host of kennedy kennedy
she's never exercised her right to
remain silent outnumbered co-host emily
compagno
she's like an alarm clock will not stop
making noise until you pay attention to
her boss's contributor cat tip
and they did his tattoos with the
seattle space needle my massive sidekick
in the nwa world television champion
tyrone
emily so many things to talk about with
you um i guess i should start with your
i we haven't talked about what happened
with cnn have we this week you and i we
haven't had a conversation not yet maybe
we should let's go somewhere
what do you think is going on what's
happening
uh well i think they're this is the
consequence of everything that you laid
out perfectly which is them existing in
an echo chamber and the fallout is real
um if you mean in in part the sort of
chris zucker thing that fallout you know
that's all born out of uh chris claiming
that he is owed millions it's all about
money right he says well the reasons
that you terminated me zucker blessed at
the time in fact he encouraged my
brother andrew to come on he encouraged
me to do these things and so the lady
the lady right the oh yes
yes thank you darling so uh people
there's uproar there as well why does
she get to hold our job ironically under
the state law that chris's brother
helped initiate she would be subject as
well to termination so there's a lot
going on there behind and and in front
of the scenes uh and in terms of you
know i thought your diversity point was
really interesting because in the joe
rogan thing when you see the amount of
public figures who have come out in
support of joe rogan that's pretty
diverse right everyone from the rock to
marianne williamson to jewel they're
sort of a diverse representation they're
athletes and the like and that tiny
group of basically crosby stills nash
and young who are are canceling
themselves
they're all the same right there are
cnn uses the same clump of consultants
and experts for their network and rogan
all rogan does is look for other other
people by the way barbra streisand
has also joined the boycott of spotify
which makes her part kennedy of the
streisand effect
right barbara streisand is fulfilling
the streisand effect by drawing
attention to the very thing she's
criticizing
that could make my brain explode yes and
now because of that everyone has access
to the beach in malibu thank you so much
barbara
um
but it's it's really interesting because
joe rogan at least is being honest about
what he's doing he's like yeah i'm just
a guy who has questions who's talking to
another person yeah and sometimes we do
it for three hours right and people go
oh i want to listen to that because uh i
didn't even think of that question
that's great so he's being very honest
about what he's offering uh cnn is full
of hot wind because you know they're
saying we are a trusted news network we
have a health department and a newsroom
and we're newsy news people and you
should trust us to get your news right
but that's not true this was actually a
very powerful guy who had failed upward
through several media companies who
thought that andrew cuomo was going to
be president uh hitched his wagon to the
elder cuomo star and kept the dum-dum
meathead employed to pacify andrew cuomo
and also have a mouthpiece at cnn and i
just want to apologize for something
last night on my fox business show
i called jeff zucker i i said that he
was jabba the hutt's foreskin and i want
to apologize for that because i wish i
had saved that and said it on your show
first
wow
that's quite an image
and i had such a good point to make on
your point but now you've like like a
pool cue you just went poop you knocked
my idea out of my head with that thought
cat is the legacy media dead
uh not yet no but i think also if people
only saw cnn from watching clips on the
show which i think a lot of people do
they would be shocked at like those are
actually really well produced clips yes
like most of it doesn't even look that
good it's like some guy on a zoom call
in a basement somewhere and like it's
cutting in and out it's like nobody
would ever want to watch that no matter
what they're talking about and again
when when stelter's like to your point
when zelda says joe rogan wins it it's
like that's what people like yes that he
goes and being like i don't know i want
to talk to this guy see what this guy
thinks we'll have a conversation you
don't need to watch brian stelter's show
to know what he's going to say you
already know yeah that's true i like to
watch it with the sound off tyrus
before we get to the whole stelter thing
with you yes
i was confused i always thought jabba
had the same problem that merman had
since their bottom half is a fish and
his is a worm i didn't think
so you are fact checking a disgusting
joke hey it was a great joke and it made
you think because i thought
and i thought i always thought that he
had the same problem apparently i was
wrong listen don't yes i know how much
brian stelter means to you and i know
deep down in places where you don't want
to bring up unless we're sitting around
you
that you're worried about him not being
on tv yes and then you won't see him
anymore no i know that's exactly that's
right so
i believe we have the transcripts yes
with the tape however you want to put it
sure uh where i ask the question
if there's any artists watching the show
tonight if you could please drop me a
picture of baby gut filled wrestling in
stelter's bosom that would be
so amazing
and
greg yes
your wish
was your fan's command
and uh
an iraq veteran named clutch has
provided us with
a dream that is so adorable
so you will always be together wow that
is beautiful we'll get it framed nice
keep it in your cabin and drink wine to
it i think that is uh that is
almost exactly the proportions right yes
yes
yes
right next to ebb vegota you'll be
together forever yes we should try to
hire them if they'd get to get rid of
them just so we could have them around
here yes and have them on the show
so the so the picture's not enough yeah
i always want something
i never can get enough tires well okay
especially all right all right back to
emily
all right i made him uncomfortable
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else